the best way to outperform everybody in  your business or at least keep up in  very competitive business and Joe Rogan  is a beautiful example of this is to  take excellent care of your health yeah  you've got sunlight exercise Stress  Control through physiological the double  inhale long exhale through the mouth try  and be a nose breather and not a mouth  breather put yourself into uncomfortable  cold three or five days a week avoid  toxic relationships those would be the  recommendations there are a bunch of  others and I'll keep spouting them out  on the internet doctor [ __ ]  Cuban man just saved your life okay you  could do all that stuff or you can just  go get peptides like the rest of us  because we're not gonna go we're gonna  do psilocybin we're gonna smoke weed  we're gonna not do Fentanyl but we're  gonna definitely do what is it doing the  other one salmonella